Hallo herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt ich bin tim brett love und ja ich habe mir,
wieder nochmal ein anderes thema rausgesucht von all den dingen die einen gerade so um die ohren fliegen rundum die krise und das ist die aktivität die jetzt gerade aus der zivilgesellschaft kommt um die
versorgung der krankenhäuser rettungsdienste und
anderer leute mit material zu versorgen und spreche mit felix felix just hallo felix.
Schönen guten abend.
Felix sag doch mal vielleicht kurz was zu dir was was du so machst und was du so schaffst.
Bin felix achtunddreißig bin in berlin großgeworden verdiene mein geld wenn's sein muss als sap-entwickler,
mache kommunalpolitik in friedrichshain-kreuzberg für die partei.
Ein großteil meiner zeit geht mittlerweile für den x drauf den ich vor vier jahren eröffnet habe das ist der heck und make space in dem viel von dem läuft was gerade was ich gerade so tue.
Ja x ist einer von ich weiß gar nicht wie viele wie viele makers spaces zählt es denn eigentlich gerade so in berlin und unmittelbaren angrenzenden umland so aus deinem deiner erfahrung heraus.
Das ist immer schwierig weil die grenze so bisschen verschwimmt was ist noch makers space was ist schon nur noch auf eine werkstatt ist es in heck space oder ein hack und make space oder nur ein maker space,
ich glaube in berlin sind wir rund zwei handvoll heck und max ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie viele von den klassischen offenen werkstatt im sinne von gemeinsame fahrradwerkstatt oder so ist es,
da habe ich keine übersicht.
Ja gut davon unabhängig was ist denn der x genau und warum habt ihr den gegründet und was macht er so.
Also ich habe den vor vier jahren gegründet weil ich ehrlich gesagt einfach das bedürfnis hat dann mal so ein bisschen die coolen dinge zu lernen bei sap vieles ist aber nicht.
Ich selber gar nicht so über zuhause alleine mit videotutorials klassischer nerd so vor sich hin programmieren kann sondern es ist eigentlich immer eher in sozialen runden garten und da viel besser lernen kann,
habe ich einfach gedacht okay dann öffne ich jetzt eröffne ich es einfach ein raum wo die ganzen leute hinkommen die das coole zeug können und dann wird das schon irgendwie auf mich abfärben.
Habe darum vor vier jahren einen kleinen raum in friedrichshain gemietet und.
Also in berlin.
Genau er hat berlin friedrichshain und bin dann eigentlich mehr oder weniger losgelaufen und hab gesagt liebe leute ich habe einen raum ich würde den gern gemütlich machen und zu einem gemütlichen hacks space hier in friedrichshain weil in friedrichshain gab es zu dem zeitpunkt noch kein.
Und dann sind glücklicherweise erstaunlich viele leute schnell aufgelaufen und haben geholfen in in einem sehr gemütlichen raum zu verwandeln.
Dann ist das jetzt dreieinhalb jahre fleißig gewachsen und letztes jahr im sommer hatten wir das große glück umziehen zu können einfach nur ins nebenhaus und haben uns aber von vierzig auf knapp zweihundert quadratmeter vergrößert bei der gelegenheit.
Genau wir sind jetzt von damals fünfzig auf knapp neunzig mitglieder gewachsen,
es ist sehr querbeet das publikum und die projekte also von drucken laser karten,
elektronik basteleien klassische nerd projekte wir haben eine wir sind dabei unsere nähecke immer weiter aufzubauen bauen im keller und der holzwerkstatt aus.
Es ist viel mit basteln aber auch menschen die die ganze zeit nur an ihrem laptop setzen und nie einen schraubenzieher in die hand.
Wie viele leute gehören so zum dunstkreis.
Wir haben ich glaube fünfundachtzig zahlende mitglieder im letzten monat gehabt und so der harte kern die so mindestens einmal im monat oder öfter auftauchen sind doch schon so dreißig bis fünfunddreißig.
Das ist schon ganz ordentlich.
Auf jeden fall.
So jetzt gab es ja im zuge der sich entwickelnden gronau krise diverse berichte darüber das material fehlt und überall
in deutschland also eigentlich auch weltweit gab's denn gerade in dieser mekka hacker space bewegung relativ schnell so die reaktion mit
oder viel zeug irgendwie was gar nicht mal so kompliziert ist im eigentlichen sinne vielleicht können wir da ja was
machen man hat euch dieser gedanke erfasst.
Tatsächlich ging das verhältnismäßig bald los dass man da irgendwie angefangen hat mitzukriegen was was so passiert in der welt weil also,
nun in deutschland nicht losgegangen
aber es ging schon deshalb schnell weil wir angefangen haben deutlich mehr bei uns irgendwie im chat herumzusitzen und irgendwie uns in videogruß zu treffen weil wir den ziemlich schnell auch für öffentliche veranstaltungen geschlossen haben und alles abgesagt haben.
Dann war ja was macht man dann gemeinsam irgendwie jeder alleine an seinem projekt basteln in einer videokonferenz ist halt auch nicht so.
Klar will man ja auch helfen und insofern sind dann schon eine ganze zeit lang die verschiedenen vor- und nachteile der verschiedensten varianten diskutiert worden,
dann ist beim auch im member von uns im krankenhaus arbeiten ziemlich schnell klar geworden,
wir müssen hier irgendwie tatsächlich auch in berlin scheinbar helfen beim anfang hat man immer gedacht in italien müssen sie das jetzt machen aber wir in deutschland der sieht ja alles irgendwie,
noch viel entspannter aus die werden das schon hinkriegen wir haben ja gar nicht so viele tote und das kann ja nicht so eine katastrophe werden bei uns und das war immer,
in die ersten paar tage was zumindest für mich auch immer eher so ein ich sage mal ein interessen so mit was kann man machen aber noch nicht dass ich irgendwie ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht habe,
dass wir das jetzt irgendwie produzieren müssen dafür.
Hat die realität dass das nötig ist war einfach bei mir noch nicht so wirklich angekommen.
Aber keinem glaub.
Genau aber bei den bei den kranken pflegern und schwestern ziemlich ziemlich schnell und dann war irgendwie klar dort werden die mundschützer knapp.
Und dann hat sich sehr schnell bei uns eine gruppe gefunden die angefangen hat stoff masken zu nehmen,
also jetzt nicht diese einfach nur einen lappen vors gesicht hängen sondern die variante mit einer vernünftigen tasche drin so dass man dann in diesem behält,
küchenrollen irgendwie filter dass da verstärken kann also dass die stoff maske sozusagen.
Dieser hongkong maske.
Ja genau so ungefähr also dass die die stoff maske eigentlich nicht das schutz-ding ist sondern der schutz-ding ist halt der papierfilter aber die papierfilter muss halt irgendwie vor dem gesicht halten,
da haben sich verhältnismäßig schnell menschen bei uns gefunden die angefangen haben zu nähen und dann kam,
letzte woche samstag der anruf von daniel domscheit-berg aus verstehe bahnhof der gesagt hat felix wir sind irgendwie fleißig am drucken von diesen schildern,
für krankenhäuser und abends arztpraxen und es hat sich herumgesprochen und wir kriegen anfragen aus berlin könnt ihr euch nicht um die kümmern,
dann hab ich ohne groß nachzudenken und sagt ja klar machen wir eine stunde später lag halt irgendwie auf den drei d-druckern die wir zu dem zeitpunkt hatten,
der erste test druck drauf und dann sind wir quasi ab sonntag eingestiegen irgendwie möglichst am fließband zu produzieren.
Und versuchen wenn möglich in kombination diese face und die stoff masken abzugeben weil gerade dann,
bringt es halt auch wirklich was also so eine stoff maske ist schon ganz gut aber wenn man ein haus husten und menschen ins gesicht guckt,
irgendwie spritzt man kann sich über die augen infizieren da ist so ein spritzschutz zusätzlich schon ganz günstig.
Ja klar also face schild das sind diese dinger die man sich oben also ihr baut quasi ein erzähl doch mal kurz was was das ist.
Genau also wir wir drucken zwei teile das eine sieht aus wie so ein bisschen ein labbriges,
reifen den man sich so vorne an die stirn gemacht,
das sind sozusagen die zwei haarreifen übereinander und an dem vorderen der mit ein bisschen mehr abstand zum gesicht sind so vier kleine knüppel dran wo man dann die folie das sind löcher reingelasert hattet einfach draufklebt,
dann kann man unten nochmal so einen zarten gebogenen begriff dran machen das hält das schild insgesamt ein bisschen gebogen um das gesicht besser abzudecken und außerdem,
verschmiert es nicht so wenn man es doch mal anfassen muss.
Das heißt dieses dieses dieses schutzschild der geht quasi von der oberkante der stirn dann letztlich bis unter das kind.
Genau also die folien die wir gerade bekommen haben sind vierundzwanzig mal achtundzwanzig zentimeter das ist so ungefähr vier kann man sich vorstellen.
Bisschen breiter ja.
Genau wir kriegen nächste woche nochmal ein bisschen größere folien.
Wir müssen da jetzt überlegen ob wir eventuell halterungen laser karten statt zu drucken weil dann geht das irgendwie schneller weil es ist zwar ganz toll mit drei d drucken aber drei truck ist halt nicht schnell.
Wo habt ihr denn diese diese folien her und was was habt ihr denn da am anfang genommen hatte die das noch irgendwas im regal oder.
Also wir hatten tatsächlich das große glück dadurch dass daniel vom verstehe bahnhof uns sozusagen um hilfe gebeten hat uns er uns gleich in kontakt zu einem hersteller vermittelt hat,
der hat uns gerade fünftausend stück geschenkt.
Wir haben vor dem parlament hersteller hier in berlin und auch hundert folien bekommen das waren die die wir letzte woche schon verteilt haben.
Also filamente ist ist diese kunststoff schnur die man letzten endes durch die düse im drei d drucker durch jagt die dann heiß wird und die sind quasi das eigentliche material zusammensetzt.
Große spulen mit zwei kilo ich sage mal faden so knapp zwei millimeter dick aus plastik.
Was kostet sowas normalerweise so ein so eine rolle.
Die kosten so um die dreißig euro das kilo.
Und was wie viel kann man aus einem kilo letztlich herstellen.
Im augenblick die variante die wir drucken das sind zwanzig gramm für das oberteil und zehn gramm für das unterteil also so ein vierzig stück.
Ja ich rechne jetzt mal dreiunddreißig aus wenn's.
Ja also ich sage mal so wenn es schnell schnell gehen muss und gerade wenn man größere mengen abgeben muss geht das halt auch mal ohne das unterteil das unterteil ist nice to have.
Verstehe ok feature.
Also genau irgendwas zwischen dreißig und vierzig kann man damit schon hinkriegen.
Okay aber kommt man dann schon so auf kosten von einem von einem euro pro teil quasi ne.
Ja und dann kommt ja noch die folie dazu also wenn man die folie also die wir haben jetzt folie bekommen die,
ziemlich dünn und labbrig das ist die ist eigentlich nicht so genial geeignet für weiß es halt null komma ein millimeter dick,
das reicht dass da nichts durchkommt aber es ist halt nicht besonders stabil wir hatten die ersten hundert die wir bekommen haben die waren deutlich dicker und stabiler,
aber wenn man die kauft dann ist man bei einem euro pro stück,
wenn jetzt bei uns bei uns sind mittlerweile anfragen im fünfstelligen bereich teilweise aufgelaufen es ist ein bisschen absurd das ist für uns sowieso nicht stemmbar.
Im fünfstelligen bereich.
Also wir haben eine große bundesweite organisation die so rettungsdienste betreuen wir haben angerufen und gesagt wir würden gerne alles nehmen was ihr uns geben könnt weil sie haben für april ihren bedarf auf elftausend stück geschätzt.
Oha okay.
Kann ich natürlich auch direkt sagen dass also in der größenordnung wird es bei uns sowieso nicht möglich werden,
selbst mit der unterstützung die wir jetzt haben aber also da sieht man mal,
wie verzweifelt die leute sind dass sie halt bei so einem kleinen hack space wie uns irgendwie anrufen und denken wir könnten den eventuell mit ein paar hundert oder ein paar tausend schießt so ohne weiteres weiterhelfen.
Ja wie lange dauert denn das so ein so ein ein einzelnes teil zu produzieren.
Unsere aktuelle version wenn mit ober-und unterteil braucht fünfzig minuten drucken.
Und dann nochmal eine minute um die die folie zu lasern genau also so ungefähr ein ein stück die stunde.
Ok ja da kann man jetzt schnell sich ausrechnen dass ihr da nicht in der lage seid fünfstellige summen zu machen.
Und das ist im prinzip auch das was man quasi ein equipment erforderlich ist und leser cutter um diese folie richtig zu schneiden und dann halt das teile dann klickt man das nur noch zusammen.
Also man kann die folie auch mit einem mit einem klassischen locher lochen oder.
Das geht auch natürlich da muss man sehr genau gucken dass es dann auch noch auf dieser halterung passt das ist halt mit einem laser karton ein bisschen bequemer,
obwohl wir sind ja mittlerweile,
haben sich cardios makers space und auch die beuth hochschule angeschlossen dadurch gibt's auch connections zur uni potsdam,
die jetzt experimentieren ob man das mit fräsen oder irgendwelchen aus dem druck verfahren so buchbindemaschine irgendwie da gleich so ein paar hundert folien auf einmal durch stanzen kann damit wir halt,
das beschleunigen können.
Also man sieht aber auch schon das im prinzip dazu alle mekka spaces sich da zusammen rotten und versuchen quasi alle maschinen die gerade greifbar sind in irgendeiner form zum glühen zu bringen.
Also wir haben das große glück also beziehungsweise viele make-up spaces haben ja einfach jetzt ein problem die sind vereine.
Vereinsräume dürfen zurzeit nicht geöffnet werden das heißt die kommen eigentlich an ihrer drucker gar nicht ran,
der hat jetzt einen großen vorteil wir sind eine gemeinnützige haftungs beschränkt wir sind quasi eine firma,
dadurch können wir unsere räume noch nutzen darum haben mittlerweile afra c und verschiedenste menschen ihre drucker irgendwie aus den büros und make-up spaces geholt und zu uns,
im augenblick haben wir elf laufende drucker und zwei die halt irgendwie gerade darauf warten dass wir sie morgen früh wieder.
Ok und sind die auch alle so in dem richtigen qualitätsbezeichnungen es braucht.
Na ja es ist einfach so wenn elf laufen dann machen zehn das so dass man danach das ding auch benutzen will und der eine der muss halt danach gewartet werden also es ist schon ja es ist kein replika tor so ein.
Ja aber immerhin ihr habt dann so einen theoretischen output von zehn stück pro pro stunde und dann sind das ja schon ganz klägliche mengen die dabei rausfallen.
Genau also wir sind zu der wir sind ja aber auch nicht nonstop da das heißt wir waren jetzt letzte woche so zum schluss so bei achtzig hundert vielleicht hundertzwanzig stück am tag,
jetzt gerade sitzen unsere leute online zusammen und basteln unsere version ein in so einer gesteckten version dass man sich so aufeinander stapeln.
Damit man zum beispiel über nacht die dinge laufen kann nicht morgens nur ein stück hat sondern vier bis sechs,
das macht es dann auch ein bisschen einfacher immer wieder drucke zu tauschen im sinne von neuer abholen und anderem werfen weil im augenblick muss man halt verhältnismäßig viel auch vor ort sein um das zu machen.
Wenn man das so ein bisschen in größere etappen kriegen wäre das ganz hilfreich.
Das heißt da findet jetzt auch noch eine ganze menge optimierung statt während des prozesses und das ist ja sicherlich auch so eine belastung die er so auch noch nicht gesehen hat normalerweise macht man mal so ein teil und dann trinkt man kaffee.
Also da sind wir so dass man an einem teil immer weiter rum optimiert das sind wir als make-up durchaus gewöhnt wir haben auch x projekte die wir seit mehreren jahren als als gruppe mit uns rumschleppen und die jedes jahr irgendwie,
wieder abändern oder weiterentwickeln die geschwindigkeit ist unüblich sage ich mal,
also wenn ich mir überlege wir haben am samstag das s l also das ist dieses dateiformat für drei modelle das uns daniel empfohlen hat einfach ohne nachzudenken auf den drucker gelegt und haben angefangen etwas zu drucken,
mittlerweile ist es glaube ich die vierte version angepasst damit es hier ein bisschen besser ist und da ein bisschen stabiler,
innerhalb von einer woche wo irgendwie einer von unseren membern dran ist und zwei leute,
auf twitter gemeldet haben wo ich außer den twitter nicht keine ahnung habe sind die kannte ich vorher nicht die waren keine follower aufmerksam geworden gefragt ob sie helfen können dann haben wir gesagt ja hier habt ihr das rtl,
und dann haben sie sich angeschaut und haben gesagt ja aber wenn du das und das noch besser macht dann geht das schneller und haben uns das wieder zurückgeschickt und genau.
Ausprobiert und ging schneller.
Schneller und stabiler das war echt eine große hilfe.
Also wie kriegt er denn dann das material und das volk das ist wahrscheinlich weniger das problem aber wie läuft das.
Naja also ich finde das ist halt ganz schön ein problem weil es im endeffekt.
Eine böse abwägungsfrage ist zu entscheiden wer kriegt den jetzt wie viel masken,
kriegt das jetzt das krankenhaus hier im nachbarbezirk weil die nichts weiter haben oder
gebe ich jetzt erstmal den arztpraxen im bezirk die sie,
im zweifelsfall später drankommen als die krankenhäuser oder wie viele von unseren masken geben wir jetzt sea-watch mit die nächste woche nach moria also das flüchtlingscamp in griechenland fahren.
Dann kommt irgendwie freunde die anrufen und sagen ey meine halbe familie lebt in spanien die arbeiten im krankenhaus die haben mülltüten vom gesicht und haben pro schicht fünf bis zehn tote.
Und dann sitzt man da und überlegt na toll ich habe gerade hundert schienen die ich akut direkt verteilen kann mehr nicht wer kriegt den jetzt wie viele das ist schon.
Das ist schon ein ganz schöner hammer und das hat mich auch zwischendurch ganz schön umgehauen,
am anfang haben wir halt sehr viel first come first serve einfach noch gemacht ja somit auch mit den stoff masken.
Da haben wir aber jetzt seit gestern glücklicherweise den cactus maker space das ist ja so ein ich sage mal krisen,
interventionen die laster zu krankenwagen umgebaut und ähnliches.
Die haben sich bei uns gemeldet ob sie uns irgendwie unterstützen können und die werden quasi die komplette verteilung und priorisierung übernehmen weil die erfahrungen aus krisengebieten haben wie haben die auch,
medizinisches fachwissen die sind froh wenn sie da helfen können weil sie gerade keine geeigneten maschinen haben,
und wir sind froh dass wir diese entscheidung irgendwie halbwegs geschulten menschen geben können.
Und auch die psychische last von euch ein bisschen abfällt in dem bereich.
Ja auf jeden fall also das ist uns bei aller begeisterung wie wieviel gerade passiert und,
wie toll auch irgendwie die ganzen leute helfen und bereitwillig irgendwie ihre materialien vorbeibringen die sie auch irgendwo zu hause haben oder geld spenden das ist zwar echt toll,
aber es ist ehrlich gesagt furchtbar und furchtbar beängstigend dass wir das überhaupt machen müssen.
X ist als gemeinsam genutzter hobbykeller gegründet worden nicht als unternehmen für medizinische not.
Bedarfe also es ist es ist echt scary.
Naja aber immerhin tragt ihr aktiv dazu bei dass die situation sich zumindest nicht verschlechtert so das ist ja auch schon mal ganz gut.
Also.
Was ja.
Na ja wenn wenn du noch anmerkungen hast also ich würde natürlich jetzt erst mal interessieren wie man euch,
unterstützen kann also
ich habe gesehen ja sehr ihr ruft natürlich nach spenden auf weil das ermöglicht euch jetzt quasi auch in den materialkauf zu gehen an der stelle wo nichts gespendet wird richtig.
Also genau wir haben auf masken punkt berlin so ein bisschen alles zusammengefasst was wir derzeit machen da gibt's die nähanleitung für die schlafmasken inklusive videotutorial,
pflegeanleitung da gibt's kontakte hatten wenn man mithelfen möchte im sinne von man hat material oder man hat eine nähmaschine und zuhause und möchte nähen oder man hat ein drucker zu hause,
den man teile drucken kann oder man hat einen drucker im büro stehen man zu uns schaffen könnte damit wir den bei uns laufen lassen,
da gibt's auf jeden fall kontaktmöglichkeiten da gibt's auch unsere kontonummer für spenden weil wir müssen halt auch irgendwie zeug einkaufen,
und genau also das ist so dass unser hilfs hilfs aufruf an die an die zivilgesellschaft.
Ich persönlich mittlerweile ganz hilfreich fände wäre wenn man irgendwie mal so in kontakt zum,
krisenstab des landes berlins bekommen würde falls es einen krisenstab gibt also das ist tatsächlich frustrierend.
Ich renne seit einer woche rum spreche ich telefoniere und schreibe alle möglichen leute an die eigentlich,
kontakte haben müssten oder zumindest wissen müssten an wen man sich wenden soll aber es kommt gar nichts,
diese ganze organisation läuft komplett zivilgesellschaftlich ohne irgendwie eine staatliche förderung oder anknüpfungspunkt oder koordination das läuft gerade komplett an einem vorbei,
es ist eigentlich ziemlich ungünstig.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu den maschinenpark also für für für wie viel geräte hättet ihr denn jetzt noch platz.
Also ich sage mal so wenn man wirklich anfangen enger an eng zu stapeln um zu notfall die dinger auf fußboden stellen dann können wir schon noch zehn fünfzehn stück unterbringen danach wird's knapp,
wir hätten theoretischer weise die möglichkeit im haus nebenan da steht eine gewerbeeinheit leer die könnte man spontan zur zwischen miete bekommen aber das sind dann halt irgendwie tausendfünfhundert euro warm im monat,
es muss halt irgendwo herkommen das wäre zum beispiel so eine möglichkeit warum ich versucht hatte zur senats ebene zu kommen weil wenn die uns sagen hier ihr kriegt,
fünfzehntausend euro dann können wir den raum für drei monate mieten können weitere drei-d-drucker kaufen und könnten.
Vielleicht doch irgendwann in richtung vier fünfhundert stück gehen also im augenblick ist unser ziel nächste woche zweihundert stück am tag zu produzieren.
Da ist dann eher die frage also wenn man jetzt einen schwung neue drei-d-drucker kaufen könnte dann fallen die auch nicht gleich so schnell wieder auseinander,
könnte man auch verhältnismäßig verlässlich die ganze zeit drucken.
Und man musste dann aber vielleicht auch irgendwann mal darüber nachdenken dass die leute das alle ehrenamtlich neben ihren home-office jobs irgendwie machen.
Beziehungsweise freiberufler sind und alles gerade absagen was irgendwie anläuft oder in kurzarbeit.
Kann man schon fast sagen zum glück werden die leute nach hause geschickt weil dann können sie wenigstens bei uns helfen.
Ja
Es ist aber auch nicht toll weil wir können sie nicht entlohnen.
Na klar na klar ja felix hast du denn sonst noch eine anmerkung zur situation.
Ja merkt euch einfach selbst wenn er eine maske habt zuhause bleiben ist trotzdem besser als mit maske rumlaufen.
Ansonsten ehrlich gesagt ich bin zurzeit mit dieser ist es tut total gut irgendwie was machen zu können,
aber gleichzeitig ist man halt so man fühlt sich trotzdem ganz schön hilflos und insofern ich ich versuche gar nicht so den großen blick gerade zu machen ich versuche irgendwie so.
Zwei drei tage voraus zu denken und irgendwie meine meine to-dos abzuarbeiten damit wir irgendwie schnellstmöglich so viel wie möglich hilfe verteilen können.
Und ich hoffe dass wir das ganz ganz ganz schnell nicht mehr machen müssen.
Also so sehr spaß macht das will ich nicht weiter mit dem examen machen wir wollen gerne wieder hobbykeller werden.
Ja ich glaube wir wollen alle wieder dahin wo wir vorher waren aber ein bisschen durchhalten müssen wir noch
ja trotzdem mal ganz stellvertretend für alle bedanke ich mich auch mal dafür den einsatz so dass auf jeden fall eine wertvolle geschichte und.
An die anderen weiter.
Ja ich hoffe auch dass ihr dann vielleicht auch noch ein paar leute zugehört haben die vielleicht noch ein paar drei d drucker im keller haben oder material oder was auch immer oder auch einfach nur gute ideen und remote editing fähigkeiten ich denke da kommen überhaupt jetzt gerade in dieser situation viele leute auf einmal auf die idee
dass sie ihre skills auf einmal auf eine art und weise einbringen können wie sie es vielleicht selber auch nicht so für möglich gehalten haben ich meine es geht euch ja im prinzip genauso.
Ja auf jeden fall also wer helfen möchte wie gesagt masken punkt berlin es gibt für alle hilfsangebote abnahmen ähm auch wenn man nähen möchte keine nähmaschine hat,
ist kein grund sich nicht zu melden wir haben zwischenzeitlich mehr nähmaschinen gehabt als menschen die nehmen also ruhig melden wir können jede hand.
Alles klar ok vielen dank felix für die ausführung.
Gerne drauf dann macht ihr einen.
Ja und ja danke vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei ukw bald geht's wieder weiter.